so what are the chances Biden getss
impeached here now with analysis law
professor and Fox News contributor one
of my favorites Jonathan Turley you know
Jonathan Karine jeanpierre said that
Biden knew about hunter's stunt his
defiant stunt where he didn't show up
for his deposition and you said that
this was a breathtaking mistake
why well there are about four articles
of impeachment that are the most likely
to be pursued by the committee one of
them is obstruction another is the abuse
of power having the president involved
in advance in any way uh to the contempt
of congress uh is the worst possible
scenario for the Biden team I can't
imagine how that could have occurred
it's not that you're telling a father
not to speak to his son but you give
very clear instructions that you it's in
neither of your interest interest for
you to discuss his testimony before
Congress it certainly wouldn't be in
your interest to talk about the
potential Commission of a federal crime
contempt of congress is a federal crime
and the Department of Justice
aggressively pursued people like Bannon
and Navaro uh for not appearing in a
committee so if the president knew about
that in advance and supported it uh it
just gives another front for Congress to
pursue in in
uh
inquiry yeah it's a great point that you
bring up I want to ask you about this
this was buried deep in a political
article an axios article rather and it's
about the relationship of the president
with his attorney general we know the
doj is independent but it says this
Biden's relationship with Garland his
attorney general which has already
become more frigid um is now tense those
close to Biden argue Garland's trying in
vain to satisfy bad faith GOP critics
one person unflatteringly compared
Garland to Comey uh saying that both
have been obsessed with the appearance
of having Integrity what do you make of
this well if it's frigid now it's going
to be perfectly glacial if the house
moves to hold his son in contempt
Garland is already on the record his
Department of Justice pursued those
earlier cases it just took a couple of
months before Bannon went from not
appearing to having an indictment so I
don't see how mer Garland could do
anything but prosecute uh Hunter Biden
if the house approves uh a contempt uh
uh resolution but the interesting thing
is that Garland did something for Biden
uh that was invaluable he refused to
appoint a special councel to look into
the corruption Scandal many of us have
been writing for years that we can't
even imagine his rationale Joe Biden's
name is all over these files there's
millions of dollars is going to his
family and the circle is coming closer
and closer to the president and yet
merri Garland has simply refused to
appoint a special counsel and so I think
President Biden's got to give more
credit than he's giving
them Professor Jonathan Turley brilliant
as always thank you very much hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else